all right in today's morning rounds a
new study finds that cutting just 300
calories a day could have a huge impact
on your overall health researchers
followed groups for two years and told
them they could eat whatever they wanted
to but they had to restrict calories so
on average the group cut about 300
calories that's the equivalent of about
two chocolate chip cookies or about a
cup of ice cream Samantha Heller is a
registered dietician at NYU Langone
health and she joins us now good morning
how are you I'm doing very very well
so um everybody knows what they need to
do to lose weight and to be healthy it's
just really really hard to do it so what
are the health benefits well I think
people think they know what they need to
do but I think they might be surprised
that it can be easier than we do think
it doesn't have to be severe calorie
restriction we don't have to starve
ourselves we don't have to do extreme
diets what this study found in healthy
or just slightly overweight people was
that restricting as little as 300
calories which is almost nothing as you
just pointed out can result in
significant weight loss about 16 pounds
over two years not everybody is that
patient yeah but they had better cardio
metabolic profiles that means there they
had better triglyceride levels lower
cholesterol they lost visceral fat their
bodies got healthier their heart got
healthier and what was interesting and I
think and they didn't discuss this in
the study is because people are saying
okay how am I gonna cut these calories
today I think they became more mindful
eaters so they started making healthier
choices as well countable when you
really pay attention I don't have to
write it down or log it in some way but
first what is visceral fat what is that
that's the fat that it gave me like deep
under your belly you can't see it and
that is a more dangerous kind of fat it
increases inflammation and our risk for
heart disease and liver disease I have
always I thought visceral was something
you could see like muffin toppers but
I've always heard calories in calories
out that that's it doesn't even matter
what the quality of the calorie do you
think that's true
I don't I think that you can lose weight
eating cup
thanks but it's not healthy if you eat
fewer cupcakes then you normally eat
turnt in terms of calories and day
you'll probably lose some weight but so
the quality of the calories matters and
I want people to focus on being healthy
and not being skinny so I think what we
can take home from the study is when
you're going to eat something say is
this healthy for me today is this how is
it gonna make me feel when I finish
eating it is is this respecting this
body that's trying to keep me alive all
day I do fear that the cupcake diet may
be trending ontwitter after they say
yeah but so we mentioned the top 300
calories a day that's about 2
chocolate-chip cookies if you're not
able to count in your head on that how
do people track the calories oh you can
just look at the Nutrition Facts label
the serving size and sometimes that's
tricky it is but there are a lot of apps
right that I mean I used an app called
lose it bet yep works really really well
it's free and it allows me to put in
what I'm eating I can even take a photo
of the barcode right and it immediately
goes into the app and tells me the
nutritional value and I can add it to my
counter of calories and fat all right
the portion is what gets a little dicey
when we're using some of those apps so
it may underestimate your calorie intake
but 300 calories is you know a soda and
a bag of chips okay it's really pretty
easy to cut 300 Cal I use Weight
Watchers now known as WW I think there
are many ways that you can count your
calories sure but for those of us that
don't use all of these apps do you have
something that you think is really quick
and a really good recommendation that
you should cut x y&z we're gonna I hate
the word cut by the way Samantha I just
don't want to deprive myself but do you
have recommendations on what are easy
switches cheese on everything we eat
it's you know one ounce of cheese which
is only about that much it's about a
hundred calories I think it's illegal to
only eat that much cheese right so we
eat a lot of cheese to cut back on your
cheese consumption don't put five slices
in a sandwich put one or two you know in
you know measure your portions of rice
or pasta measure them for about a cup
and then add a whole lot of non starchy
vegetables broccoli kale spinach
mushrooms things like that fill it out
with that and then have some healthy
protein with that doesn't be thoughtful
I've been living the 300 calorie a day
cut life since I read about this in fact
because I was doing the the space
coverage and the astronaut
165 pounds and exactly my height but I'm
25 pounds heavier and I was wrong years
are working it is I think feel good yeah
are you know in two years thank you very
much for being here you